jakl le docteur gubler
sortie sans commentaire du docteur
gugler après son audition dans les
locaux de la police judiciaire l'ex
médecin de françois mitterrand a été
entendu pendant près de quatre heures
comme témoin dans le cadre de l' enquête
préliminaire pour atteinte au secret
professionnel sur plainte de la famille
mitterrand après l' ordonnance de référé
plusieurs qui interdit la diffusion du
libre les éditions plon n'ont pas encore
décidé si elle faisait appel elles ont
quinze jours pour le faire en france 40
mille exemplaires du grand secret ont
été vendus mercredi unique journée de
diffusion la fnac a décidé de reverser
les bénéfices de cette vente à la
recherche sur le cancer
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
claude gugler dans les bouches du rhône
en pleine nature
c'est entouré d'olivier qu'il profite de
son havre de paix et s'adonne à sa
passion la photographie d'oise la
photographie les oiseaux c'est des
heures et des heures d'attentes pour une
photo il y à un pic épeiche qui est dans
le chêne on va tâcher de le prendre et
puis de vous le montrer
[Musique]
les oiseaux il suffit d'attendre y en a
et ne pas leur faire peur c'est
l'art de la photographie
et la patience ne suffit pas toujours
parfois il faut changer de poste
d'observation
je prends en apercevoir
on regardera il n'est pas peu fier de
l'avoir enfin rattraper cet oiseau à
travers son objectif
un pic épeiche c'est un pic épeiche sur
le chaîne qui est là que nous venons de
voir je vais
l'imprimé on va regarder voilà mon pic
épeiche
une passion qu'il anime depuis des
années voici quelques cinquante mille
photos prises à travers le monde tous
les albums
l'équateur le costa rica la tanzanie les
galapagos le chili çà cette eau aux
galapagos
[Musique]
il est l'heure pour claude de remplir
ses obligations de la journée direction
la mairie de cuges les pins une petite
ville de 5000 habitants dont il est le
premier adjoint au maire depuis 2007
[Musique]
plainte et quelques années que j'exerce
mes fonctions d'élu je suis maintenant
premier adjoint responsable des finances
et du personnel et de l'informatique
bonjour c'est dur mais bonjour qui
voulaient bien rentré dans mon bureau
prenant son rôle très à coeur il va
jusqu'à recevoir ces rendez-vous dans le
bureau du maire
[Musique]
la journée continue au secours populaire
de la ville visite hebdomadaire madame
la présidente
madame lamoureux secrétaire général
madame lasseube l'automne où tu vas bien
me séry convient tout à fait en forme la
madame mauricette lamoureux qui est la
présidente du secours populaire qui
dirige cet établissement depuis combien
de temps maintenant ça fait cinquante
cinq ans sans le secours populaire à
cuges il y aurait des gens qui restait
sur le sur le
le carreau toutes les semaines une
distribution de vivres est organisé et
claude vérifie que tout est prêt à
partir de 16h30 à peu près temps
d'entendre les familles vient dont
celles qui sont inscrites sur la liste
de maurice est amoureux bientôt et on va
leur distribuer certains noms aux deux
produits est venu
comme ça bon ma petite morrish est un
grand merci un assez bon c'est pour tous
au revoir au revoir ma belle
de retour chez lui il est accueilli par
le gardien de la maison son chat bonjour
ma peau m ça c'est mon chat bonjour
calypso
dernière tâche de la journée claude va
chercher de quoi dîner dans son potager
un poivrot n'est donc amoureux de la
nature et de la bonne cuisine 6 les
petits bourgs rovère alors qu'ils sont
délicieux free on les trempe comme comme
une frite dans la friteuse et c'est un
régal alors j'aime bien être là
là vu que j'ai sur q j'ai été assez
extraordinaire à l'aller
ce grand-père de dix-huit petits-enfants
coule désormais des jours heureux en
provence
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
le docteur gugler claude bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde a parlé vous
n'êtes ni le 14 mai 1934 à paris dans le
14e votre père était suisse allemand
géologue il avait établi la cartographie
du laos du siam et du tonkin l'indochine
de l'époque puis vers un petit peu de
renseignements pour le deuxième bureau
sinon huile a dû en faire le
gouvernement français quand il est
devenu français lui a demandé compte
tenu du fait qu'il parlait lui lang les
suisses sont des gens qui parlent
beaucoup même s'ils sont quelquefois
très muet
alors au retour d'une mission
la gangrène l'emportent en 48 heures
tout à fait c'est un
quelque chose
et qui est dans ma tête parce qu'on me
l'a dit je ne les ai pas vécu j'avais 6
ans de mon père j'ai très peu de
souvenirs puisqu'il était tout le temps
soit en mission sans un travail de
terrain de recherche de cartographie
comme le font tous les géologues et
il est mort
où on s'est toujours interrogé nous ses
enfants et même ses amis sur les raisons
de sa mort
ma mère était une scientifique un très
intellectuel très brillante a jamais
voulu que je me penche trop sur le
pourquoi ces reste un point
d'interrogation car votre mère géologue
elle aussi tout à fait on lui doit la
découverte des gisements pétroliers du
sahara et des landes ce qui est quand
même pas rien tout à fait tout à fait
sacrée famille oui alors vous passez
votre prime enfance à rabat au maroc
alors vous regardez de vagues souvenirs
de cornes de gazelle avec le thé le
chaouch de mon père qui était le celui
de s'occuper donc des affaires de mon
père et de ma mère et qui nous habitait
dans la médina à prendre le thé avec les
fameuses cornes de gazelle et cornes de
gazelle c'était pour moi
les suprêmes les scorpions et ça c'était
un ver colomb béchar où on allait passer
quelques vacances et ou de nous était
interdit de quand on était petit de
faire quoi que ce soit avec mon frère
qui a deux zones différence avec moi
nous allions chercher des scorpions que
l'on prenait pour s'amuser et la rouge
ce que nous avons reçu voilà c'est
ponctuel mais mes souvenirs de du maroc
tout à fait alors à la mort de votre
père en 1940 vous rentrer en métropole à
toulouse je voudrais un petit détail
humoristique si je puis dire de cette
rentrée en france c'est que les trains
marocain qui devait nous amener prendre
le bateau à oran pour traverser la
méditerranée comme nous sommes arrivés
avec eux des heures de retard le bateau
était parti et on a dû prendre le
suivant et je rappellerai que le bateau
qu'on aurait dû prendre cette laie
lamoricière il a coulé corps et biens
dans la baie de marseille on aurait dû
être voyez le hasard fait des shows
voilà quand vous arrivez à toulouse
c'est moins drôle parce que c'est la
guerre dont les tickets de rationnement
les galoches en bois tout à fait c'est
une période très dure très triste
d'abord notre mère puisqu'on nous sommes
quatre enfants notre mère devait
travailler pour nourrir si je puis dire
travailler aux pétroles d'aquitaine
comme on était au début portionné à
sainte barbe ou les punitions
corporelles existait à cette époque
encore chez les franciscains on n'avait
pas à manger on était obligé de voler
ont été obligés de pour moi qui n'étais
est-elle troisième c'était les habits
suivant c'était les chaussures un petit
peu éculé les galoches comme vous venez
de le rappeler effectivement ce n'est
pas une vie même si toulouse est une
ville rose
alors en plus la maison est en phase d
usines dewoitine donc ils sont bombardés
la nuit d'où nous avions dans le jardin
un abri un creuset dans lequel nous
descendions la nuit ont quelquefois
notre mère nous emmener parce qu'il y
avait trop de risques j'ai une amie à
elle qui habitait à côté de la gare
matabiau qui était bombardée
et on descendait la meilleure les abris
alors la fin de la guerre débarqué à
paris à janson de sailly vous êtes
condisciple de jean becker le
réalisateur de jacques lafleur le le
héros de la nouvelle calédonie de
philippe labro écrivain journaliste
effectivement il y avait pour nous
jeunes et un peu pauvre je dois dire de
voir
jacques lafleur de voir
jean becker avec des costumes
magnifiques et sapé comme dominent
tellement on allait faire des parties
d'échecs au bois de boulogne ont séché
les cours on avait chacun une préférence
et finalement ont formé une bande d'amis
assez sympathique alors vous qui vouliez
devenir juge ou avocat vous allez
devenir maître ça effectivement j'aurais
voulu être avocat ou mais peut-être tech
trop paresseux pour faire des études
supérieures
alors vous voulez vous spécialiser dans
plusieurs disciplines la cardiologie
l'hématologie la cancérologie ce qui
fait qu évidemment vous installer très
tard et là vous garder un pied à
l'hôpital et un pied dans votre cabinet
dans le 6e arrondissement à paris xème
arrondissement est un quartier tout à
fait particulier participent à ce que
vous devenez le médecin des artistes
picasso
salvador dali rené char oui oui c'est
tout à fait vrai vous soigner aussi les
hommes politiques et le premier contact
avec la famille mythe errance est en
1967 quand vous venez soigner la mère de
danielle mitterrand madame vous au
domicile des mitterrand rue guynemer tu
avais comme on dit vulgairement pignon
sur rue puisque c'était à côté de chez
eux un de leurs amis à la mort de
jean dayan qui était le médecin de la
famille blues et mitterrand le radis
mais il ya du blair qui est là il est et
il est bien tu verras il est bien bon et
je suis monté là vous rentrez dans la
famille voilà alors pendant plus de dix
ans elle poursuit vos activités dans
votre cabinet de la rue saint placide à
la clinique des soeurs augustines et
vous occuperez de françois mitterrand
entre autres à l'époque il est insolent
de bonne santé est résolument hostile
aux médicaments 1 je dirais même que
quand ils venaient en consultation que
ce soit la clinique où dans mon cabinet
ou quand j'allais chez lui c'était
toujours pour me dire ne pas de
médicaments un bon ok ce que j'ai vu on
sait rien c'est rien c'est non c'est non
mais je n'avais rien alors lorsque
françois mitterrand est élu en 1981 vous
devenez son conseiller médical spécial
il a 64 ans c'est un roc il a aucun
problème de santé est d'ailleurs le
premier bulletin de santé dit rien à
signaler tout va bien effectivement
enfin batterie d'examens comme il
l'avait demandé comme il avait souhaité
que cela fût et ses batteries d'examens
cliniques et biologiques de montres
strictement rien donc ras mais à
l'automne 1981 en voyage au mexique
mitterrand a de fortes douleurs
lombaires au retour on fait des examens
assez clandestinement d'ailleurs au val
de grâce et le verdict tombe cancer de
la prostate avec métastases trois ans à
vivre alors pourquoi n'avait-on pas vu
ça lors des examens du premier bulletin
de santé parce que on ne fait des
examens que sur une symptomatologie
maintenant les faits même sens
symptomatologie bah oui c'était comme
marie scanner
avait rien il ya à l'époque de ses
thèses faisait pas comme ça d'une part
et noto pas on ne ne dit pas quelqu'un
qui paraît être en bonne santé et bien
je vais vous faire un scanner cérébral
pour découvrir un anévrisme ou irm pour
découvrir un onirisme je dire on ne veut
pas faire un corps entier ou faire une
scintigraphie osseuse pour s'émanciper
alors qu'il ne souffre de rien ce sont
des examens coûteux oui ce sont des on
est même s'ils ont maintenant c est
moins mais nous sommes quand même nous
médecins responsables de quel point ce
qu'ils appellent la sécurité sociale est
demandée plein d'examen pour rien ouais
me semble être inutile or ce monsieur
était devenu président de la république
mais que je suivais qu'il avait aucun
signe clinique d'appel voulons dit
car il est vraisemblable que
c'est cette symptomatologie
découverte en novembre 1980 un existe
est peut-être en avant mais on était
complètement occulté je puis dire
n'était est révélatrice de rien rien
rien aucun signe ouais je veux je pense
qu'aucun médecin n'aurait pu trouver
alors là on lui dit vous avez trois ans
à vivre quand on vient d'être élu
président un public c'est horrible parce
qu'ils l'avaient attendu pendant pendant
toutes ces années d'être président au
moment où il est président et c'est vrai
ce que condamne c'est vrai horrible
alors aussitôt mitterrand vers où il un
faux et vous dit on n'en parle pas même
à daniel et lorsque vous allez lui faire
sa perfusion à 7h30 du matin rue de
bièvre si des fois elle vous demande
pourquoi vous êtes là vous dites c'est
un rhumatisme récalcitrants oui à partir
du moment où le patient lui-même demande
à ce que les choses ne soient pas dit
à qui que ce soit vous devez vous plier
à ces exigences de patience donc de
trouver une excuse
si
je ne souhaite pas qu'on dise à ma femme
ou à la maison pour le moment que je
suis malade le médecin alors évidemment
c'est un petit peu plus délicat lorsque
on est dans une situation aussi attentes
à 1 10 on a une image
ya auquel il faut pas toucher donc ça
posait un peu plus de problèmes que pour
un patient ordinaire alors
lorsqu'arrivent les chances du deuxième
bulletin de santé là il est plus
question de transparence vous vous
suggérez d'au moins parler d'examen mais
mitterrand est catégorique il vous dit
on ne peut rien révélé c'est un secret
d'état et pour bien vous faire
comprendre dans quelle situation vous
êtes il vous dit vous êtes liés par ce
secret tout à fait vous avez là une
documentation tout à fait au fait des
choses il lui dire monsieur oui oui
c'est tout à fait vrai nom le jeu mettra
d'une tout petit détail supplémentaire
c'est qu'en fait compte tenu des
résultats que j'avais je lui dis très
simplement si on ne fait rien on laisse
passer l'échéance 1 on ne fait plus de
bulletins de santé oui je ne veux pas
si j'ai promis aux français de dire
jeudi mais alors je dis que non vous ne
le dites pas ça a été une petite partie
par et tombent entre nous deux et
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent à me
convaincre bon certains à cette époque
mon numéro est reparti mais on
n'abandonne pas malade on n'abandonne
pas un malade quand on est médecin ou
qu'on aime son métier quels qu'ils
soient qui sont un chauffeur de taxi ou
qu'il soit président de la république
c'est donc le troisième communiqué c'est
tout va bien rien à signaler et alors
pour faire face aux rumeurs mitterrand
donne une interview dans laquelle je dis
que tout va bien je vends une chose
c'est que
et la veille l'histoire l'a montré c'est
que ce monsieur
a merveilleusement
réagi à la thérapeutique et que je
pourrais
je les dis défier quiconque à travers
les résultats des examens de 1982 de
dire qu'il avait quelque chose ouais que
ce soit des examens cliniques qui a été
donnée par le professeur steg examen
clinique bien sûr la normalité ou au
contraire l'anomalie non professeur seck
disait lui-même au président de la
république et vous êtes comme un homme
de votre âge en occultant leur chaude
qui ne n'était plus visible même par les
examens biologiques alors effectivement
miraculeusement énergie de françois
mitterrand revient et pendant quelques
années le cancer se tait complètement
vous vous le suivez donc quand même et
vous accepté d'endosser un rôle de
composition pour protéger le secret du
président vous cacher un peu derrière le
masque du du bénin serviable mais alors
on va passer à l'elysée avec vos favoris
comme ça tout le monde voulait j'en tire
évidemment personne c'est la vie ça me
fait plaisir de pouvoir rire
c'est tout à fait ça ça a été un jeu de
composition pour moi d'être d'être but
vous savez ce d'être le plus proche
possible de ce qu'ils regardent
qu'est-ce que quand on est très proche
de quelqu'un et bien
on le voit plus mais combien de gens
dans la confidence je dirais que
allez peut-être pas une dizaine un peu
moins un peu moins amis ou politique
mais danielle mitterrand le savez un non
pas du tout pas du tout ainsi en 1992
mais alors on mai 1988 françois
mitterrand est réélu il a oublié sa
maladie tout va bien et elle se réveille
en 1992 et c'est là que ses liens avec
vous vont se distendre parce que
désormais mitterrand a pris conscience
de la mort aux rats et des devant son
problème il ne peut plus regarder en
face celui qui sait tout je dirais qu
1992 est opérée dans une première
intervention en 1992 après son discours
avec philippe seguin sur maastricht à la
sorbonne et on l'opère le lendemain
matin
tout se passe bien dans ce que vous
dites docteur c'est que quand il a fait
cette émission de télévision avec ce
gain et guillaume durand le lendemain
matin il sait qu'il va subir l'opération
je crois que l'émission c'est a duré une
partie de l'après midi on on s'est
séparés pour aller dîner chacun de notre
côté on s'est donné rendez-vous sa
voiture est venu me prendre
rue dufour je crois ou quelque chose
comme ça mais nous sommes entrés à
cochin où il a été opéré le lendemain
matin par le professeur steg alors
l'année 92 est encore une année
je ne dirais pas correct mais
le françois mitterrand était un homme
de la terre et qui a toujours refusé
dans sa tête que l'on s'attaque à sa
chère il disait lui même et b vous
rendez pas comme ça tu entraînes à 2,2
de m'ouvrir et de c'est vous qui allez
disséminées tout ça c'est pas moi moi je
je je maintiens tout ça malheureusement
la symptomatologie était telle qu'il
fallait l'opérer mais c'est plutôt 93 93
et 94 qui vont être des années un peu
charnière voyez c est la deuxième
intervention ses 94 la deuxième
intervention beaucoup plus difficile et
c'est a pas deux font la queue aux
aguets il est en face de la mort mais il
a souvent été dans nos relations
intellectuels se et vous le savez vous
même combien de fois il parlait de la
mort c'est écrit dans tous les les
livres de biographique sur lui ses
visites dans les cimetières ise cc c'est
parler de la mort en général mais il
m'en parlait même à moi et je lui avais
cette réflexion je lui disais mais
attendez cuisez pas fichés mois la
famille avait dû m'arriver quelquefois
dû dire ficime la paix avec votre idée
vous êtes encore vous avez encore envie
de séduire vin est un séducteur qui
avait encore envie de séduire je dis pas
séduire les femmes séduire au sens vrai
du terme résume un des hommes par votre
part votre regard vous voulez les
séduire et tant que vous aurez cette
envie vous êtes en vie - si donc
l'arbitré mort et vous avez raison de
leur nom est alors à ce moment là
effectivement vous vous savez tous voulu
rappeler la vérité voulu rappeler les
bulletins de santé mensongers
donc il a du mal avec vous à partir de
ce moment là
que la médecine traditionnelle
ne peut plus rien pour lui il est comme
vous venez de le dire en face
de l'autre face du miroir et je
représente non seulement celui qui
traîne la balise de la mort depuis 14
ans mais en plus
mon impuissance dans la qualité de la
médecine que j'apporte à réaliser un
musicien un miracle comme on me l'a dit
faites un deuxième miracle sinon je ne
peux pas faire à partir de ce moment-là
il connaît mme may psychorigidité comme
il l'appelle luthérien comme il le dit
et il
va se tourner vers d'autres médecines un
peu parallèle un petit peu hors d'usagé
et il ne m'entraîne pas dans ce jeu et
je ne me laisse pas entraîner dans ce
jeu par rapport à ces médecines c'est
vous qui l'aurait amené le le docteur
tarot est un excellente
anesthésistes et qui est
spécialiste de la douleur or à partir de
1993 il commence à avoir mal donc je
fais appel à jean pierre thareau je vais
le chercher il ya un bon mal
il faut il faut faire quelque chose et
donc gens bien tard or entre un petit
peu là et effectivement je pense que
pour n'importe quel malade
le l'homme qui vous suppriment la
douleur quelles que soient les drogues
qu'on donne pour supprimer cette douleur
devient quelque chose de très important
bien sûr il donné quoi la morphine
je n'étais pas dans ses bagages mais
c'était si moi j'avais été un char en
charge c'est ce que j'aurais donné mais
c'est très vraisemblable est-ce qu'on
peut gouverner un pays en étant souvent
et bien écouté pendant une courte
période je dis bien une courte période
il n'était pas apte et qui le lui
j'étais très gênée par un c'est bien
c'est bien parce que quand vous donnez
un certain nombre de chose à quelqu'un
quel qu'il soit le pet chauffeur de taxi
président de la république ou le pape il
y a des conséquences je pense que si
quelqu'un était
le pilote de 1 747 et qui était avec des
terry serait de par la médecine du
travail arrêtée alors vous apprendrez la
mort de françois mitterrand par les
journaux personnes de la famille ne nous
a prévenus pourquoi la famille non mais
jean-pierre tao m'a appelé en me disant
7 heures du matin je crois huit jours
après le décès de l'ancien président
vous publié chez plon un livre intitulé
le grand secret où vous révéler
effectivement que le cancer avait été
diagnostiqué dès 1981 que les bulletins
de santé étaient mensongers et que dès
1994 le président mitterrand n'était
plus vraiment capable d'assumer ses
fonctions en deux jours vous vendez
40000 livre donc un livre que vous avez
créés et michel gonnot pourquoi mais
vous écrit ce livre n'est pas parce que
je le lui avais dit que j'écrivais que
ne maintenant que c'était sur la place
publique qu'il avait un cancer je
remettais des choses en place chaque
fois que je le voyais musée alors avec
un sourire ironique où en sont vos notes
et je rappellerai pour ceux qui ne
savent pas que dans un livre écrit par
monsieur benhamou qui serait le dernier
mitterrand il dit que
le dernier réveillon ou avec des
ortolans il parle vous savez que blair
écrit un livre donc avant qu'il meure on
savait que j'écrivais un livre vous
aviez choisi michel gonnot parce qu'à
l'époque vous lui avait filé des
mauvaises informations on n'est pas bien
sûr avec mon sourire ironique donc est
donc là vous faites le livre
dévoile alors là évidemment vous traînez
extrêmement médiatiquement célèbre
quelles ont été les réactions au moment
de la publication du livre blanc il y a
eu un tollé général et que je peux
comprendre compte tenu de la dda courte
période dans la mort et la publication
du livre
que j'ai pas pu arrêter mais bon qui
n'aurait pas eu lieu si le livre était
paru trois mois ou six mois après 1 sur
ces c'est la date qui qui qui est
surtout
polémiste lien cc c'est pas c'est pas le
livre lui-même donc une levée de
boucliers politiques médecins
bon ça a été une période
de chocs de difficulté que ce soit cette
médiatisation que je m'attendais pas du
tout deux journalistes qui me convainc
près de nous les avoir d'avocat
d'avocats
plus ou moins retors et méchant je ne
citerai pas dedans mon b tout le monde
comprend instructive me parler personne
personne
n'a dit mais attendez avant de mourir
françois mitterrand voulait trois choses
la vérité sur sa fille plein mazarine la
vérité sur avec payant sur la sphère
bousquet oui et la vérité sur sa santé
quelqu'un aurait dit ça
tout partait les proches les amis et je
savais et le savez quand vous voulez
trois choses la vérité c'est la raison
pour laquelle il m'avait dit vous dirai
la vérité vous êtes un un psychorigide
et relu taille mais je dirais oui c'est
sûr alors est ce que ce livre a rapporté
de l'argent pas du tout dans un premier
temps il a été interdit après il a après
l'arrêt de la cour européenne y est
reparu mais
les sept cet ouvrage les comme on dit
les
les droits d'auteur ont été
intégralement versé à ma commune dont
nous sommes en rien la première a porté
pendant toute cette époque donc avec
mitterrand oui quel a été le meilleur
moment
je ne dis pas le les meilleurs mais man
qui sûr qu'ils sont tous les mêmes c'est
des moments de solitude à 2 en se
promenant pourparlers et le pire moment
notre cette époque un moment où du rêve
92 comme ça où il a voulu arrêter son
traitement
est là où je lui ai dit attendez c'est
fini si vous arrêtez j'ai pu vous en
être là
je mentais n'ai plus besoin de soigner
et incivilités au traitement alors deux
jours après la publication du grand
secret le livre est retiré de la vente à
la demande de la famille mitterrand vous
êtes condamné à quatre mois de prison
avec sursis pour violation du secret
médical et 50000 euros de dommages et
intérêts et radié de l'ordre des
médecins s'est beaucoup l'allemagne ça
s'appelle le un coup de massue sur la
tête
pour écraser le mot juin radié de
l'ordre des médecins c'était le
professeur glorion qui à l'époque était
résidente du conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins or comme vous le savez je
n'exerçais pas moi j'étais inspecteur
général des affaires sociales moi
j'avais pas médecin je ne vivais pas de
mes revenus et de médecins tôt que ce
n'était en valeur à quel qu'il soit fou
et que tu es moi de l'expression ça ne
fait quoi on leur a dit et voitures
vivre avec il est fonctionnaire et
pointures vie
ce qui n'empêchait pas le conseil
national de l'ordre de me recevoir avec
un tapis rouge enfin parce que j'étais
inspecteur général et attentionné que je
réglais les problèmes de l'application
des mesures européennes sur les
professionnels de santé voyez il ya une
espèce tout à fait une espèce de
drôlerie de la vie absurde ce n'est
qu'en 2005 que la cour européenne de
justice vous donnera raison le livre est
réédité et donc depuis on peut le
trouver absolument
alors là aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque de l'hélice
brin du touât bon ça vous manque pas du
tout arcanes du pouvoir du tout pas du
tout jamais été d'ailleurs dans les
arcanes du pouvoir un du tout pas du
tout fait de la rancune contre quelqu'un
la reculée d'un mot que j'aime pas mais
il ya des êtres humains je n'aime pas
beaucoup hein alors j'en citerai un
monsieur georges kiejman ouais georges
kiejman parce que si l'on se rappelle
bien les faits à un moment donné
danielle mitterrand a dit mais non mais
non je ne veux pas que dublin de la
prison quelque chose comme ça et madame
ezratty qui était président de la cour
d'appel a dit mais attendez donc on
arrête tout et jean schéma n'est d'aller
revoir derniers n'ont alors que daniel
aurait été dur bon vous aviez soigner
son mari pendant tellement d'années oui
c'est pour ça que avec le recul même le
juge de la chambre qui m'a condamné dit
en privé que c'est une des
des
jugements qui lui reste en travers de la
gorge parce que en dix ans mais il n'a
jamais dit qui le met ses mains c'est
une des affaires qui l'allumage en doute
le plus d'aidés plus si je puis dire dr
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
ne referiez pas pareil
je crois que dans la vie
les échecs qu'ils soient professionnels
ou sentimentaux les coups de bâton
c'est positif pour moi donc
les choses ne seraient peut-être pas des
mêmes parce que les événements de
septembre et même mais je ne changerait
pas d'un iota notre attitude mon
attitude elle même elle changerait pas
c'est comme ça j'ai fait ce que j'avais
à faire je continue à faire ce que je
fais c'est que je suis comme je suis
alors le jour vous allez mourir un
cassoulet comme écrivent sur votre tombe
sur ma tombe serait écrit fo guillon
aurait les heures s'enfuit accès 12
ténébres et il était arrive look
so terminé ternes aux manettes mais la
lumière demeure dans l'éternité alors
est ce que comme françois mitterrand
vous croyez aux forces de l'esprit
ne sais pas le mot jean perret moi je
suis plus croyants si je puis dire mais
ça peut se rejoindre
je pense que il ya quelque chose qui
subliment notre cher propres le fait
même de se parler comme on se parent
fait qu'il ya quelque chose qui reste et
c'est ce quelque chose qui pour moi est
la lumière dans l'éternité très bien
merci j'étais très heureux de rallumer
la lumière sur le remercie claude les
clous on est sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu